of course it's muted tell me no it's
muted they can't hear it just kidding I
wasn't really on a hot mic there but for
a second you thought I was about to get
caught on a hot mic saying something
back here welcome to the stream I have a
lot to talk about and I'll get right
into it momentarily I want to talk about
what do I want to talk about there's a
new poll which shows that even if Robert
Muller proves collusion obstruction
crimes whatever Republicans still don't
want Trump impeached and removed which
just further confirms why I think that
the path forward is just to vote Trump
out in 2020 okay at this point we're 20
months away and if you're hoping for
removal via impeachment it's just what
are we doing in 20 months we can vote
the guy out impeachment and removal
would take that long and Republicans
wouldn't do it anyway so we're going to
talk about that momentarily we are also
going to talk about some right-wingers
are losing their mind over Nancy Pelosi
saying that she would be fine
investigating Donald Trump's adult
children obviously not Barron the things
he's doing with computers might be
amazing but she's not talking about
investigating Baran and it's really no
big deal I mean it's it's off obviously
they should be fair game because they
are advisors and they are involved and
Ivanka's sitting in for the Secretary of
State or did for Rex Tillerson so it
makes perfect sense there's absolutely
nothing untoward or concerning about
that so we will talk about that as well
and as people are coming in I will
remind you live streams are live
differently different than the videos
that we upload to YouTube you can
participate the best way to do that is
by using the super chat function that's
the dollar symbol at the bottom of the
chat window if you have a question for
me if you have a comment that you want
me to read and react to use the dollar
sign at the bottom of the chat window
always great to hear from people seeing
what's on their mind so on and so forth
I will open up the phone lines during
this live stream if and only if iff as
we say in the world of philosophy
I will open up the phone lines if we get
to ten new members and that would be at
WWN pakman.com there is a coupon code
which expires tomorrow night we've
extended it's 64 60 it'll save you 60%
I'll talk more about that later
please don't troll the live chat please
don't troll the live chat please don't
troll the live chat it's just annoying
and it's sad it's just a depressing
existence to be trolling people's
streams if you want to troll send a
super chat and at least pay for it and
you can also use the join button below
the video window to become a YouTube
channel member that will also pop up
like a super chat so we for example see
that just 10 minutes before I started
Lance Smith became a YouTube channel
member and that's really great and I am
I'm getting a flurry of texts from Kyle
kolinsky yeah Wow okay I'm gonna have to
deal with that later kyle kyle is on
fire right now and i can't even tell you
what it is because i don't fully
understand that i just took a quick
glance but we'll deal with kyle a little
bit later okay so all of that stuff
being said let's just get into what i
was hoping to talk about today the first
news story that i want to talk about is
a new poll which tells us what a lot of
us expected most republicans would not
support impeachment of donald trump even
if robert muller proves that he accepted
russian assistance would which would be
a crime or obstructed justice according
to a new poll let's look at the details
most republicans wouldn't support
impeaching President Donald Trump even
if special counsel Robert Muller found
that the billionaire worked with Russia
to get elected president in 2016
survey from YouGov The Economist asked
respondents if they would support or
oppose Congress beginning the
impeachment process a special counselor
Robert Muller found a number of
different things among them that Donald
Trump accepted Russian assistance during
the 26
the presidential campaign that would
effectively amount to the collusion
allegations that Trump has repeatedly
swatted away as untrue but most
Republicans would not want the president
to be impeached even if Trump did accept
Russia's help 63% of Republican
respondents said they opposed
impeachment in that situation while just
18% supported and 19% weren't sure and
most of the Republican Party most
Republicans also wouldn't want Trump to
be impeached if Muller found he
obstructed justice 62% of Republicans
say they oppose impeachment in that case
while 18% supported it and 20% were not
sure this is why as a political strategy
the left just needs to forget about
impeachment they need to forget about
indictment although I think you can
indict a sitting president it's just not
a political strategy whose timeline
makes any sense what I mean by that is
the following
it's March okay
March to November is 8 plus 12 the
elections 20 months away ok if you want
to remove Donald Trump in the quickest
possible fashion vote for someone else
in November of 2020 even if impeachment
proceedings were started today by
Democrats you would number one not
necessarily have the conclusion to those
proceedings before the 2020 election but
more importantly Republicans don't want
Trump removed even if he committed
crimes okay on yesterday's David Pakman
show
I presented data which tells us that
most Americans believe Donald Trump is a
criminal 64 percent of Americans believe
that Donald Trump committed crimes
before he was president 45 percent of
Americans believed that Trump committed
crimes since becoming president of the
United States and there is overlap
between the group that believes that
Donald Trump is a criminal and the group
that wants Donald Trump to be re-elected
and approves of the job that Donald
Trump is doing you can't convince them
it's not a political strategy and
Republicans in the Senate who are going
to
trol the senate all the way up to the
2020 election and the 2021 january
swearing-in of the people that win or
lose they are not going to act to remove
Donald Trump if a majority of
Republicans despite Trump's criminality
don't want him removed and that's why
when we look at the new data that's
presented in this poll and it says even
if Moeller proves collusion illegal
collusion receiving of things of value
from foreign powers obstruction of
justice or has a strong case for it
believes Donald Trump has committed
those acts they don't care and this is
why you need to start just focusing on
get out the vote for 2020 okay when half
the country doesn't vote you can win
just by getting people who already agree
with you to go to the polls and cast a
ballot okay you don't have to argue with
a single trumpet I'll keep doing it if
they call into my show but it's more for
fun and because I'm doing a show as a
strategy to win elections all you have
to do is get people who say yeah I think
Trump's are criminal and I'm progressive
or I'm moderate or I'm liberal or
whatever and I don't approve of this but
I don't usually vote get them to go to
the polls you cannot rely on any
impeachment and that's why my position
from the beginning has been
investigations that are going on or
legal and they are warranted and there
is probable cause they should continue
when we have the results we should
evaluate the results if the correct
thing on the basis of those results is
to start impeachment proceedings then
start the impeachment proceedings but it
is not a strategy you can't run on it
and it's a loser's game to simply be
counting on that as a way to remove
Donald Trump and I hate to say this
because it's so embarrassing I mean it
truly is embarrassing
there's a very good chance Trump gets
reelected in 2020 I'm not trying to game
you in order to get you to vote when you
otherwise don't want to the way that the
electoral college works combined with
half the country not voting combined
with the fact
Trump seems to have this immutable base
of 35% support means that there is a
very very good chance that Donald Trump
is going to be reelected in 2020 so I
don't want to be playing the
i-told-you-so game on whatever date in
November of 2020 this is going to come
down to turnout this is winnable but we
can't be waiting around for Republicans
to get a conscience and then choose to
remove Donald Trump it's just not going
to work okay the second story I wanted
to talk about today and by the way this
this is a live stream it's really live
unless you're watching a replay if you
have questions for me if you have
comments for me if you want me to
address your concerns it's as simple as
using the dollar sign at the bottom of
the chat window use the dollar sign it
will pop up your question or comment on
screen I will read it I will thank you
and then I will answer it or comment on
it if it's a comment rather than a
question I am also ready to open the
phone lines to you at six one seven
eight three zero forty seven fifty as
soon as we get ten new members either on
our website at join pakman.com or via
YouTube and I will start thanking people
we already have a few people who have
signed up and I do want to mention that
we have just an extraordinary coupon
code available which expires tomorrow
night at midnight we have reached
600,000 subscribers on the YouTube
channel and because there's a six in
that we decided to do a 60% discount off
of membership ok the coupon code is 64
60 that's 6 0 for6
0 if you take a 6 dollar membership and
apply the coupon code you're talking
about 2 dollars and 40 cents a month if
you take the coupon code and apply it to
a 60 dollar membership that's only 24
dollars for the year two bucks a month
this is mostly how the program is funded
people know that our YouTube ad revenue
has been all over the map
ever since ad pocalypse in April of 2017
where we lost like ninety nine point
8% of our YouTube revenue for a period
of several weeks it's not a big ask
we're talking about a couple bucks I
know a lot of people in the audience can
afford that and if you can go to david
pakman.com slash membership use the
coupon code 64 60 I will thank you we
will all have a great time and then I
will open up the phone lines and it's a
win-win-win for everybody okay Nancy
Pelosi is okay investigating Donald
Trump's children pointing out that they
are advisors to the president
Republicans are going absolutely bonkers
about this and I truly don't know why
there is just nothing even remotely
remotely controversial about this we're
not talking about going after children
we are talking about investigating the
possible lies wrongdoing and criminality
of adults who number one have very
creatively circumvented anti-nepotism
laws number two have not been confirmed
by the United States Senate number three
have at least as far as Ivanka Trump and
Jared Kushner are concerned have
security clearances that they should not
even have and there is absolutely no
reason whatsoever that they should be
off-limits from investigation I am
willing I'm starting to channel steven
crowder any argument that you believe is
a strong argument for having Jared
Kushner and Ivanka Trump and Don jr. and
Eric Trump be off-limits
I want to hear okay leave me a voicemail
send me a tweet send me an email send a
super chat whatever because I have
examined this over the last couple of
hours from a legal standpoint I have
examined it from a logical standpoint
and I can think of no reason why we
should say that Donald Trump's children
are off-limits not talking about Barron
okay I'm talking about the ones that are
the UH that are advisers who have not
been Senate confirmed shouldn't have
security clearances
but somehow do let's see the content of
the article here some House Democrats
have a
expressed reservations about going after
President Donald Trump's children in
their oversight investigations into his
administration doesn't make any sense
there should be no reservations and
fortunately as this article says Speaker
Nancy Pelosi is not one of them they are
investigating certain subjects
whoever falls into that net falls into
the net there is this hilarious series
of comments I saw on Twitter from
Republicans saying can you imagine if
Republicans went after Sasha and Malia
no I mean just just know it's it's a
mind-numbing ly stupid analogy Sasha and
Malia were not adults they were not
involved in Barack Obama's
administration period I I almost feel
like there doesn't need to be anything
else said they simply are not what
Donald Trump jr. is or what Ivanka Trump
is or what Eric Trump is or what Jared
Kushner is and it makes absolutely no
sense the House Intelligence Judiciary
Oversight and Financial Services
committees have all opened up
investigations touching on Trump's
personal finances and how they may have
influenced his campaign and
administration the intelligence panel
has also reopened its probe into Russian
interference in the 2016 election and
possible ties to Trump's campaign Pelosi
said any investigation that involves
Trump's children such as daughter Ivanka
Trump or her husband Jared Kushner would
be prompted by allegations from other
witnesses and in media reports that they
have violated the law or ethical norms
not by their familial relationship to
the president obviously they're not
going to be investigated because they
are Trump's family members they are
going to be investigated because they
are adults who are involved in his
administration period they are advisors
to the president they have security
clearance this is not Trump's children
at home it's not Baran I don't even know
if Trump talks to that Tiffani Trump I
believe she's an adult she's in her
early 20s I think I'm just going from
memory it's not clear Trump likes her
but she as far as
we know has not been involved in
anything related to the administration
so if she committed a crime it would be
like a local law enforcement matter for
police to investigate Jerrod who's not
Trump's biological son of course Ivanka
Eric and Don Jr are involved in the
administration they have security
clearances there is nothing
controversial here the president
indicated this week that he plans to
cooperate at least to some extent with
some of the Democrats as investigations
I cooperate all the time with everybody
but he also referred to the federal and
state probes into his political and
financial world as a political hoax
Trump has mostly spoken negatively about
the sweeping investigations the list of
federal state and congressional
investigations into his 2016 campaign
and business dealings are all quote
[ __ ] he proclaimed before a crowd at
CPAC over the weekend earlier this week
the White House wrote in a letter to
House Oversight and Reform Chairman
Elijah Cummings
that it will not cooperate with this
panel's probe into the administration's
security clearance policy I feel like we
are living in a world that is it's
idiocracy it is backwards these are just
basic things these are these are legal
investigations every legal argument that
has been made against the investigations
has fallen flat robert muller is
operating in completely within his legal
capacity he is a Republican he is not
any kind of plant or shill or someone
that the Democrats have conjured up in
order to punish Trump for things that he
didn't really do wrong there have been
no leaks from robert muller there have
been allegations about Peter struck
being a partisan in his role as someone
who was involved in the investigation on
Mulder's team Muller handled it
completely correctly as soon as it was
revealed that Peter struck sent these
politically charged text messages he was
dismissed and of course there's no
evidence that his political bias
influenced the investigation in any way
and by the way breaking news everybody
who's involved in the investigation has
personal political views there's
way to avoid that there is no way either
no matter what you are going to have
people with a political perspective that
are participating in investigations the
question is are they allowing those
politics to supersede in importance the
facts of the investigation the process
which they have to adhere to that's it
and if you don't have evidence of that
what are we even really talking about
and it is truly disgusting that
Republicans continue to insist on this
stuff and then now this new stuff about
they're targeting children they're
targeting family they are targeting
people who are advising Trump who are
sometimes filling in for the Secretary
of State as Ivanka Trump did for Rex
Tillerson they have not been confirmed
by the Senate they are a national
security risk by virtue of the security
clearances that they have even though
they shouldn't period that's it Nancy
Pelosi's right this isn't a cheerleading
of Nancy Pelosi unilaterally or
unconditionally she's just right and
there's no good argument against it okay
I want to thank a couple of people that
have done some really great things over
the last few minutes Cyrus Palmer is a
new YouTube channel member who used the
join button right down there and that is
one out of ten when we get to ten I will
open up the phone lines
janet campbell is a new youtube channel
member also using the join button down
below thank you very much I also want to
say thanks to Tyrone Thompson who has
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership using the coupon code 64 60
he saved 60% and we are now 3/10 of the
way to me opening up the phone lines
also want to welcome Michael Suffern who
is the new david pakman show member
painful price by the way thank you very
much Michael that is four out of ten and
Amanda Blakely has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership using the
coupon code 64 60 she's paying two
dollars and 40 cents a month and she is
new member number five of the evening
when we get to ten I will open up the
phone lines if you are just joining me
we
have been talking about a new poll which
tells us that even if Robert Muller
credibly demonstrates that Donald Trump
received things of value from Russia for
the purposes of winning the presidency a
crime even if he obstructed justice
almost two-thirds of Republicans
wouldn't want Trump removed from office
which is not surprising but it is
disturbing we've also been talking about
Nancy Pelosi saying she's fine
investigating Donald Trump's adult
children who are his advisers and of
course she should be and there's no good
reason to be against it
we also are if you don't know what I'm
talking about when I say 64 60 this is a
program that is mostly funded by our
audience we have something called
membership which you can sign up for at
david pakman.com slash membership the
normal rates I find to be very very
reasonable they are six six dollars per
month for one month or $60 for one year
however I understand that that is a lot
of money for people in terms of money
that they have available to support
independent media so in celebration of
having achieved 600,000 subscribers on
our YouTube channel and by the way we're
already at like six hundred and three or
six hundred and four thousand we have a
60% discount off of membership available
which expires tomorrow night at midnight
the code is 64 66 zero for6 zero this is
for a lot of people in our audience not
a lot of money but you'll feel good if
you're supporting the work that we do
YouTube revenue is unpredictable ad
revenue is unpredictable membership
allows us to build a steady stream of
income which allows us to do whatever
stories we want to do we don't have to
worry about are they are they work safe
stories are they ad safe stories it
simply doesn't matter we do what we want
because of membership and if you can
afford two bucks a month I'm asking for
your support that allows us to do the
show for everybody who can't afford to
pay anything and
that's that I love thanking members the
coupon code is 64 60 we are actually we
are a 6/10 of the way there because
Adrienne aller has also now signed up
and four more members and I will open up
the phone lines and I look forward to
hearing from you
toreano Johnson has sent the first super
chat of the evening a dollar 99 Tori on
toe says blacks for Bernie blacks for
Bernie not Harris because of Breakfast
Club interviews
yeah I saw Kamala Harris's interview on
The Breakfast Club with Charlamagne tha
God and other people I don't remember
who else is on that show and I mean
listen I I don't necessarily have a
problem with anything Kamala Harris said
in the interview on principle I don't
have a major problem with it actually
maybe I shouldn't say that in the pieces
that I saw I didn't have a major
disagreement on a lot of the policy I
just don't find her credible right now
that she she says oh she smoked pot and
no remember what else but as Attorney
General of California she was singing a
very different tune and making a lot of
different arguments in terms of how she
carried out her duties as Attorney
General you could say well that was just
the law and that's what she had to do
yes and no there's prosecutorial
discretion the Attorney General sets the
agenda in terms of what prosecutorial
and law enforcement not law enforcement
but but justice system priorities are
going to be the idea that she's all
about pot and she smoked pot and I think
she joked about being partially Jamaican
or whatever it just it didn't it didn't
sit with me as credible and it didn't
sit with me as genuine so I tend to
agree with you
Tory Anto okay biz Wiz sends a $9 99
cent super chat financial advisors tell
us that to be financially stable we must
be debt-free shouldn't this apply to our
economy regardless of job growth how can
our economy be healthy if we're so deep
in debt no no no no no okay so let's see
if we can break this down in its
component parts the
first thing you're making bhisma's is an
analogy between being debt-free as
important for individuals to being
debt-free as important to the country
there are massive differences between an
individual and an economy number one
it's not a foregone conclusion that our
priority should be to debt to be
debt-free let me give you an example if
mortgage rates are three-and-a-half
percent and you have $200,000 and you
could buy a house for $200,000
you're debt-free are you better off than
if for example you put 20% down on that
$200,000 house which is $40,000 you get
a mortgage for a hundred and sixty one
hundred and sixty thousand dollars at
3.5% and you take the 160 and you put it
in index funds which historically over
long periods of time returned 8% you're
paying 3.5% on your mortgage but over
time you're going to earn 8% on the
stocks and bonds on the index funds and
mortgage interest is tax deductible are
you better off financially by not having
the debt and just buying the house cash
for $200,000 the answer is no why do I
bring this up before we even get into
the further analysis because your
initial assertion that it's always
better to be debt-free is not
necessarily true there are many
situations in which one would opt for
debt because they have calculated that
it makes more sense in the long term so
that's number one it's not always better
as an individual to be debt-free number
two individuals can't print money
individuals can't set monetary policy
individuals suffer very different
consequences if they delay paying debts
that they have so there is simply no
analogy between an individual being in
debt and a country being in debt and
then beyond that there's modern monetary
theory there's all sorts of other stuff
that I'm not going to bore the audience
with right now but I completely disagree
with your framing bhisma's but I
appreciate you sending a super chat for
$9.99
and Smith sends a $4 $0.99 super chat
what are some of your favorite bands
that you listen to most and did you
listen to the Argentine rock band soda
stereo I yes I love soda stereo favorite
bands I don't know I mean it's it's this
is like saying what's my favorite book
but there's a lot of Argentinian bands
that are really good I'll mention some
of them since I think it's more likely
people in the live audience haven't
heard of since they're not from
Argentina there's a Argentinian reggae
band called las penitas who are really
really good there's an argentinian
reggae band called Dos Caras that are
awesome there's an Argentinian sort of
ska band called
Dos Passos Cadillacs which means the
fabulous Cadillacs there are man there's
so many good Argentinian bands I can't
even remember them all but those are
some that's probably enough for hours of
fun on YouTube checking out some of
their cons Oh South IndyGo so they got
in this another really good band okay
let's say another couple thank yous here
we're looking for 10 new members and we
will open up the phone lines
Gregory canna Mon kina Mon Kenna Mon I
hope I'm pronouncing that correctly is
number seven this evening and Paige
Ramey is number eight this evening if
people want to call in and talk to me by
the way there are so we we've already
recorded some live calls that are going
to be going up over the weekend there's
a guy named Jimmy from Philly from
supporter who called in he was furious
with me
I mean unhinged fury and he was furious
about my characterization of Trump
supporters and he ended up hanging up on
me it's a crazy crazy phone call we're
going to call it something like furious
Trump astiz completely unhinged that's
already been recorded it's going to go
up over the weekend and I welcome calls
from from pused so if you want me to
open the phone lines to more members and
I will do that membership is very varied
it supports the work that we do you go
to WWE a common comm pick your
membership six dollars a month apply the
coupon code 64-66 zero
for6 zero it'll drop it to do two
dollars and forty cents a month that's a
damn good deal if you pick a yearly
membership and apply the coupon code
sixty four sixty it will drop the $60 a
year membership to just twenty four
dollars for the year okay that's two
dollars a month that is not a lot of
money and it goes directly all but like
a three percent payment processing fee
it goes directly towards funding of the
program and doing a lot of doing a lot
of very interesting and cool things by
the way I'm not even supposed to
announce this yet because it's all it's
been tentative for months but we are
very close to finalizing the details for
a debate between me and a very very
prominent right winger I think you're
gonna like this in fact I think that the
punditry sphere is going to go bonkers
once I announce who I'm tentatively
debating if we get to ten new members
tonight I'll open up the phone lines if
we get to fifteen I'll tell you who that
person is and I think that people will
be titillated and fascinated by who I
might be debating okay so let's make
that happen okay let's see Jacob sends a
five-dollar super chat what are your
thoughts on beto or Roarke I don't know
what to believe with his voting record
do you think he has genuinely gotten
more progressive you know I don't really
care I just don't I don't find myself
excited by the bet oh but the prospects
of a better or work presidential run I
think that it is potentially problematic
that he just lost and now he wants to be
president I know losing barely in a red
state like Texas for the Senate is very
different than then running for
president he has red state credentials
he has sort of what would we call them
running against Ted Cruz
before credentials which may be useful
in 2020 I'm just not finding myself
super excited by the possibility of a
better or work candidacy I don't know
why do I believe that he has gotten more
progressive yeah I think so
do I think that probably some part of it
has been calculated yeah I think so
and bottom line I think that there are
much more exciting candidates Jeff
Rogers is a new member that's number
nine this evening okay thank you Jeff if
we get one more one more member I will
open up the phone lines if we get six
more members I will tell you about the
very prominent right winger who has
tentatively agreed to debate me and I
think that that will be very exciting
for a lot of people one more one more
member phones six more members we get to
15 I'll tell you who I might be debating
okay Elias that at chess he says Spanish
pronunciation thoughts on candidate
Biden listen if Biden's the nominee I'm
voting for him do I like Joe Biden
personally absolutely do I think Joe
Biden is an excellent debater and would
crush Trump in debates
absolutely am i thrilled about the idea
of Joe Biden one of the more centrist
potential candidates immediately being
the front-runner in the sense that he's
polling in the lead ahead of Bernie even
though he hasn't declared yeah it's not
the most exciting thing am i an identity
voter I am NOT but I do have some
concerns about running another 70
something white guy who's a centrist
against Donald Trump because I under
about the politics of it not the
identity element but I would obviously
vote for the guy and I like Joe Biden a
lot and I think that he would crush
absolutely crush Trump in debates I
think Biden would do way better and
debates against Trump than Bernie
Sanders to be quite honest why wouldn't
I be honest of course but yeah I mean I
don't I don't it's politically he's not
the most exciting and some of his
dabbling with Republicans recently has
been not not the most thrilling to me
Jackson sends a five-dollar super chat
have you heard of the FairTax what
your thoughts on it personally I'm
skeptical as it seems to be a regressive
tax I'm not for the fair tax I'm not for
flat taxes I've made that very clear and
I don't think it's good for the economy
I don't think it is the fairest tax I
mean it's called the Fair Tax I don't
actually think it's that fair so no I'm
not for it Jackson Murphy did you see
Joe Rogan with Tim Poole and Jack Dorsey
would you consider doing a debate on Joe
Rogan I saw five minutes of it I had too
much other stuff to do and the five
minutes I saw were Tim Poole telling the
Twitter lawyer that they mostly ban
conservatives and the Twitter lawyers
saying you're basing that off of I think
like 20 people or something like that
didn't see anything else I would do a
debate on Rogan I would be glad to
appear I would love to talk with Joe
Rogan about how there's a lot of
mischaracterization of the left
happening on his program and I would do
it with total peace and love and
respectfully and politely but that's
something I would be very interested in
talking about with him
David alt is a new YouTube member which
gets us to 10 new members this evening
and that means I'm going to open up the
phone lines right now you are able to
call in if you want to participate on
the show at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47:56 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 when I promise it I do it and I
also want to thank if we get to 15 new
members I'll announce who I'm scheduled
to be debating let me see here James
Dorn is new member number 11 of the
evening Mario Claudio is new member
number 12 of the evening and Luther Yee
is new member number 13 of the evening
as I said before if we get to 15 new
members I will tell you the prominent
right winger that I am supposedly very
close to finalizing a debate with which
I think will be very exciting for a lot
of people ok 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 let's see
if we can get the phone lines running
here actually don't know if I'm
things are configured correctly oh they
are okay good before I start taking
calls people can keep calling in I'll
deal with a couple other super chats
here phrenic 32 says Tim Poole is a hack
biz Wiz petition for David Pakman to go
live on general election night I know
you want to kick back and have a drink
that night but why not do both we've got
plenty of time to figure that out
and Williams Slattery sends a dollar 99
cent super chat master sleuth 91 should
we start talking about fair markets
instead of free markets free market is a
rather question begging free for whom
and be vacuous inanimate objects can
experience freedom yeah I mean fair fair
markets are what social democracy is
it's a mixed economy
it's capitalism that is well regulated
and it sets a floor and it sets sort of
a soft ceiling in some ways with higher
taxes on the very rich and I think fair
markets are basically equivalent to
social democracy platypi
says big love from Australia thank you I
appreciate that
okay we're gonna go to the phone's 6 1 7
8 3 0 47 50 let me get everything I need
here set up to take phone calls you
should see I was going over today we
have a great new phone system which
includes caller ID and it allows me to
make notes about callers so that when I
see them pop up I can either avoid them
if they're duds or if they are tend to
argue with me or are Republicans I'm
more likely to go to them because I like
to mix it up I'm not afraid of that and
I was reviewing some of the notes we
have in the system about callers in
general and there are some really really
funny ones which maybe I will share with
you at some point in time ok let's go to
our first caller from the 6 1 0 area
code caller from 6 1 0 who's this where
are you calling from
David is ma that is you my friend hi
David this is Justin from from
Pennsylvania hey Justin what saamne yeah
I wanted to turn things a little bit
more towards disaster thinking and that
there's
because of the recent tornadoes and I
think was Alabama um or Georgia
I was thinking regarding detection and
that sort of as a way to really fight it
because um I've noticed a lot that like
big bass sounds affect affect water
Adams a little bit more than they do
affect air Adams but I mean I think
there would be a way to disrupt disrupt
this kind of weather systems a little
bit more just let me see if I understand
because I don't want to miss any of what
you're saying you're saying that you're
concerned about tornadoes and you're
thinking about using bass sounds - what
like to dissolve the tornado or what's
your idea yeah large large amplified
sound waves to nullify - no if I win
from wind cyclones I think that could
work I've never heard of that before
I've always noticed that that um well
that wood is affected a little bit more
by sound than air and I've been to many
different concerts and been near a lot
of speakers and when you and when is
really up the the air is moved a lot
more than some people notice and if you
turn up the bass portion you can direct
it a certain way I'm I did give a
speaker do you think you would need to
dissolve a tornado mm I'm not exactly
sure I had things for a partner I
haven't I haven't acted I'm just
thinking outside the box yeah it sounds
off-the-wall to me but I think it should
be researched and if the math works out
then that's interesting but I've never
heard of such a thing and I would be a
little bit skeptical until we have more
information really appreciate the call
thank you very very much let's go next
to our caller from the 7 7 0 area code
who's calling from 7 7 0 today hey David
I think that might be me that is you
who's this this is Anderson you know
Lana hey Anderson what's going on hey so
um you've mentioned a few times even
today Joe Biden being more of a centrist
candidate and that it makes you less
enthusiastic and it seems that Democrats
are in a position where they're facing
playing to the center and risking
enthusiasm or going more to the left and
risking not holding Trump voters over
and possibly reelecting Trump so for
example David from an editor at the
Atlantic had said that Democrats will
need a candidate that appeals to Trump's
weakest supporters to gain new votes and
to avoid swinging too far the left so I
would ask you would you agree with this
now or is this an opportunity to swing
for the progressive pencils
yep I think so two things number one I
think that Donald Trump's current level
of support is very close to his baseline
level of support like he's you know sort
of dithering between 38 and 41 percent
approval I think that Trump's rock-solid
committed cognitively dissonant were
with him no matter what base of support
is probably 34 35 percent so number one
I don't think that there are many Trump
voters that would even be convinced
about number two I think that
get-out-the-vote is a much more
efficient strategy than convincing Trump
voters anyway I've seen no evidence that
there's going to be an advantage to
trying to convince Trump voters from
2016 to change their vote than just
getting people who didn't vote it all
out to the polls and number three I've
still seen no evidence that Democrats
are better off when they go to the
middle rather than to the left let's go
to the left because going to the middle
hasn't really worked super well awesome
thanks
all right thank you so much for the call
okay I'll take more calls momentarily at
6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 Lance Takata is the
latest david pakman show member at david
pakman.com slash membership that's 14 if
we get one more new member I will tell
you who I am very close to having a
debate scheduled with a very prominent
right winger I think people would be
interested by that couple Super chats
before I go to the phones
debar new says you mentioned possibly
debating Jesse Lee Peterson live
is that still on I wouldn't call him a
prominent right-wing or just an absolute
crazy one
that's not who I'm talking about I would
be up for doing another thing with Jesse
Lee Peterson my audience loved it and I
don't take it seriously it's just a goof
it's fun there's nothing planned right
now but there is an idea there's an idea
for a possible event with Jesse Lee
Peterson sometime during 2019 and rest
assured I will tell you what it is at
the earliest possible opportunity jamie
Cravens
says just to thank you David I've
started the Minneapolis st. Paul yang
gang in part due to your interviews with
Andrew yang alright thank you very much
I appreciate that
Matthew Upchurch says help me taper way
this out on one hand Trump's attempts to
block the Time Warner AT&T merger
represent interfering with free speech
as far as CNN is concerned and DOJ
interference on the other hand antitrust
issue yeah so Matthew here's the deal
with the AT&T Time Warner merger as
progressives we should be against the
heavy media consolidation that has taken
place in the last 20 years we should be
against such a huge portion of all media
being controlled by so few companies and
on an antitrust basis these mergers
should be prevented that being said the
president can't for political reasons be
interfering with individual mergers it's
improper it's a potentially impeachable
offense and so progressives just have to
be able to explain that we are against
the AT&T Time Warner merger but it can't
be because Trump doesn't like CNN it's
just that that's a hugely problematic
okay
let's see who we're going to next on the
phone let's go to the 7:03 area code a
caller from 703 which i think is
virginia who's there yeah David yes
who's this yes
yeah Northern Virginia so my question
was in terms of the electoral college
and whether a progressive should push to
either abolish or reform it I was
thinking about a weight that it could
somehow go between the middle of just
abolishing it
or just keeping it the same okay so what
do you think of the idea of making it so
that instead of the majority of the vote
whoever it goes to winning the each
state what do you think of duh
I guess the Electoral College I don't
know you called him I guess that
electorate or whatever electors electors
yeah what do you think of them going
proportionally to how the people in the
state vote so like if texts had fifty
electoral votes and let's say sixty
percent of Texas went to trump and forty
percent went to Clinton then the sixty
percent of the fifty electoral votes
would go in Trump's column in the forty
percent of the fifty go into Clinton's
column just do it proportionally instead
of a winner-take-all freeze yeah that's
a total evil idea I mean either way
here's the here's the sort of foundation
for what you're suggesting states have a
lot of power to decide how they award
electors there are a couple states I
believe who already do what you're
suggesting they're just very small like
I think it's Maine and Nebraska maybe
I'm going from memory it's not enough to
really make a difference but that's a
totally reasonable thing to do the
problem with it is that in some small
states there's not that many ways that
you can divide it so like if you have a
55/45 versus 52:48 versus 5842
you don't have enough electors to slice
it that thinly so from a mathematical
perspective it's it may sort of not
really move the needle one way or the
other and kind of end up just kind of
being a dud in the middle there but
that's a totally reasonable idea either
way though the thing is either way
whether a state says we will award all
electors to the winner of the popular
vote or we will award electors
proportionately either way these are
decisions that each state needs to make
which they can do but you still have to
get them to do it right and
conservatives always say oh if you
abolish the Electoral College then
people won't focus as much on the
smaller states or the ones in more
on the coast but the thing is that those
states are already just not campaigned
in or given any thought to because
they're always just go to straight
Republican so I feel like if they were
more proportionally distributed the
electors based on who votes for who in
those states it really makes it to that
every citizen would get a chance if
you're in a solid blue state or a solid
red red state I mean even though like
the red conservatives in California
would then have more incentive to go out
and vote so I feel like it would benefit
everyone the end that's a very good
point
that's a very good point and yeah I mean
I don't like the argument at this point
that the Electoral College prevents the
small states from being ignored because
okay so the big the population centers
now are basically ignored and with media
the way it now exists things have
changed so much from how things were
when the Electoral College was
established but it doesn't really matter
if the candidate physically is in your
state or in your city anymore in terms
of learning about them obviously not
going to Wisconsin probably hurt Hillary
Clinton in 2016 but from the point of
view of you're not able to get
information unless the candidate goes to
your state I mean that's just not the
way things work anymore yeah all right
okay great thanks for the call really
appreciate it
okay we've got new member number 15 for
the evening John mark Tory so I will
tell you supposedly I'm engaged to
debate Candis Owens and the details are
still being worked out I am NOT ready to
announce more about the details yet
because I guess it would just be
inappropriate I am sort of still unsure
if it's a real thing because as far as I
know she refused to debate me in a
two-on-two thing at politican Kyle
kolinsky and I versus Candace Owens and
Charlie Kirk and just a few weeks ago
she tweeted to someone who asked about
it that she doesn't know who David
Parkman even is maybe she was playing
coy I don't know but what I'm told is
that the debate organizers and her
people are basically on the same page
that we're doing a debate and when I
have more information I will tell you
about it
it will probably be very very
interesting James Dorn could you start a
new series that explains subjects like
corporate welfare to people who might be
new to progressive ideas I like that
idea and we will explore them
Doug Condor says you do not have a
Spanish accent did you ever have one or
did you train yourself out now I moved
to the US when I was really young so I
learned English almost like a native
speaker I don't I'm not aware of ever
having had an accent in English Alaska
vapor is a new member on YouTube thank
you very much I appreciate that we're
taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 let's
go - lets go - Brody I haven't heard
from Brody for a while and he usually
has pretty interesting calls what's
what's going on by the way which Brody
is this because we have like three
trophies in ours I can can you hear me
David yes I can this is the Brody from
Dallas what's going on not much man
I actually questioned about what your
thoughts were in terms of you've been
following all this a long time about the
dates and strategies that go around the
announcement dates in terms of when a
candidate announces for example we've
seen Bernie and Kamala announced already
but we haven't seen like what we expect
I think he mentioned them today show
that I think it was you that you
mentioned that Joe Biden you'd be
surprised if he wasn't he wasn't going
to run what is there any strategy behind
when the candidates announced or is it
just kind of like when they build up
their machines when they kind of look at
like who else is running like I think
they're a tional I don't think there's
any rule so I don't think that it's the
earlier the better
I don't think it's later is better
because you sort of swoop in and
everybody is becomes enamored with you I
think it depends on what is the sort of
general sequence of events how many
other people have already announced do
you have do you occupy a space on the
political spectrum that would benefit
from getting in earlier and trying to
build support like Andrew yang has done
who just needs to accumulate donations
and name recognition so I don't think
there's any particular rule or strategy
behind it I think it's very situational
year to year
and do you think this year that we're
gonna have a lot more people announce as
we get closer to the debates sort of the
in game or do you think that word I
don't know I mean I think we're getting
close to the limit as far as the
Democratic side is like how many more
people soon there's going to be so many
people running that there will be very
little incentive to say I'm gonna mount
a campaign other than if you're Joe
Biden who's leading every poll already I
think it's gonna be a pretty uphill
battle and I have one last question why
is it that you think libertarians are
obsessed with like the idea that
taxation libertarians get a possessory
strange things and I mean maybe they
feel that that's one of their strongest
arguments that taxation is that their
slavery or whatever but it's a very dumb
argument so they would be well-served to
pick something else soon right
alright Brody talk to you later okay
couple super chats here Murphy says Oh
captain my captain I am David Parkman
thank you very much Elias that actress
says 47 months for palm Anna for what
are your thoughts I did not know that
let's see if I can pull up an article
about it Paul Manafort sentenced let's
see what we've got okay yeah there it is
X campaign manager Paul Manafort
sentenced to 47 months for fraud in
Moeller case pathetic absolutely
pathetic not even four years I I'm quite
frankly disgusted by it I think I need
to read more about it like as it says
here he was seated in a wheelchair and I
guess he's now having all sorts of
health problems was that a factor in the
sentence he potentially faced like up to
20 something years which would have
effectively been a life sentence for him
my instinct is absolutely vile and I
want to read more about that about that
and we'll have coverage on the show okay
let me take another phone call and then
we'll do other super chats let's go to I
think I'm going to miles it's a it's an
Arizona area code although maybe it's
not is
who's this from Arizona hey David boy
yeah you're breaking out who's this what
was your name it smiled
it is miles okay what's going on miles
um okay so first question is who did the
best at interrogating Michael Cohen from
last week you know I really liked Rowe
Kaunas line of questioning but I don't
know if it was the flashiest but I am
sort of partial to roe I liked what he
brought up sure yeah for me it was Roe
but also AOC I think that a good job
um and second I want to kind of so
Venezuela
you mentioned the Leninists lapse and
Venezuela and Maduro apologist and what
exactly are there more factions of the
far left than just progressives like are
there factions within the progressive
action well I mean I think so if you're
asking me to name all of them it would
be tough but yeah I mean in the same way
that you've got social conservatives
pro-business low-tax Republicans
libertarian Republicans you know the
sort of like a neo-nazi all right type
stuff I mean yeah you've also got
factions within the left but I don't
know that I've thought enough about
exactly where the lines would be I mean
you've I think the the actual Socialist
Left would be an angle people who are
not Social Democrats but actual
socialists you've got the Leninist left
that tends to do things like criticize
Venice or criticize rather defend Maduro
and Chavez defend Bashar al-assad defend
Vladimir's
that sort of what I sometimes called the
Leninist left yeah I mean there are
factions but I'd have to think about
what the full scope of them are
interesting before I just would like to
mention one last thing um Felix fader
will be testifying next week I believe
the
14 so just uh yeah more interesting
things to come I will say that no
question I think it's going to be an
interesting couple years thanks miles
great to hear from Miles from Arizona
the couple super chats to mention frog
sovan or frog oven says hi David love
your show and appreciate your thoughtful
commentary what are your feelings on the
so-called horseshoe theory of politics I
so hoarse tree theory of politics if I
understand it correctly is the idea that
the spectrum is more of a horseshoe than
a line so if it were a line you would
imagine that the further left you go the
further away you are from the far right
horseshoe theory suggests that once you
get to the extremes on either side it
sort of starts to wrap around as it may
be and the extreme far left is similar
to the extreme far right I think that I
I agree that you end up getting some
degree of agreement I'm sort of
struggling with how to say it you
sometimes end up getting people on the
far left who agree with people on the
far right
but for politically disparate reasons so
like an example would be this is not an
example of far left and far right but
like the anti-vaccine component which is
skeptical of Big Pharma and then it has
a right-wing component which is
skeptical of government and for
different reasons they're against
vaccines and they end up United kind of
across the political spectrum but it's
not for the same motivations and it's
not because they share values so I think
the horse-shoe theory is interesting I
think it accurately describes some
situations and not others IDO punty says
David how do you think the space program
will be shaped according to Democratic
Republican candidate well if Republicans
get their say the space program will be
geared around acquisition of resources
and a space force type stuff if the left
gets its way my hope is it will be based
around scientific learning and
understanding helping to improve the
odds of
humans surviving on planet Earth and
those are much more and those those
values are more in line with what I
would like to see but I think there will
be certainly differences in terms of
space exploration depending on which
side gets to make decisions let's go to
our caller from the three four seven
area code caller from three four seven
who's this where are you calling from
hey David this is Karim I'm calling from
Boston actually
oh hey Koran what's going on hey um I I
want to kind of ask you about the future
of kind of a political environment I I
was thinking about I mean we're starting
to see people who kind of grew up in a
millennial era like aoc and others get
elected but in twenty thirty years when
many many congressmen and women have
kind of grown up being all on social
media having a lot of what they say
pretty much recorder online even like
snapchat videos and other stuff just in
the mix part of who they were growing up
how is that going to shape how do you
think that's going to shape the
political environment and kind of what
politics becomes I feel like it's gonna
have a huge impact and really change
what we know politics is today
absolutely but this always happens and
that here's the one sort of caution I
would I would throw out there if you
compare the average political beliefs of
a 65 year old to those of a 25 year old
at the same time people who are 65 and
then people who are 25 there is this
huge Canyon between them on many issues
that are generational issues so we get
the idea that as soon as the 25 year
olds are in power instead of the 65 year
olds everything is going to just change
it's gonna be a hundred and eighty
degree u-turn in reality some of what
shapes the 65 year olds point of view is
being 40 years older than the 25 year
old and so there is no question that as
people in my generation become members
of Congress of the House of the Senate
eventually there will be presidents from
my generation presumably unless somehow
it gets skipped
I don't know we we shouldn't overstate
the radical way in which it will change
politics like it's not gonna be a
recognizable but you're certainly going
to start to have you know people in
power who grew up with computers and
smartphones from the time that they were
kids you're going to have people in
power who started work around the time
of the 2008 recession and all of that is
going to shape the perspective but I
just think we shouldn't go overboard
assuming the radical nature of what the
change will be yeah I completely agree
and I was thinking also along the lines
of like if snapchat had been around
while you know like what Cavanaugh was
accused of Wow
during that era if snapchat had been
around there'd be a lot just a lot more
evidence about what people couldn't
agree on like where the party was stuff
like that you know when it comes to like
scandals and what politicians say behind
closed doors I feel like there will be a
kind of a significant impact couldn't it
really more couldn't agree with you more
but it's important not to you know it's
like with we talked about demographic
changes are going to make it so that a
Republican never wins in Texas again you
know the reality is things move much
more slowly things move much less
acutely there will be counter forces to
demographic changes in Texas so you know
let's let's be realistic about our
predictions for sure I appreciate it
thank you appreciate the call okay let's
go to a super chat from Brian Cole T I'm
kind of like weirdly related to Brian
Cole D by marriage in a way even though
I'm not married it's a long story for a
different day love the show Dave keep up
the great work the judge for manna for
thought that punishment was too harsh
hopefully his next sentencing goes
better oh he thought that he thought
that the like 20 year recommendation was
too harsh or thought that 47 months was
too harsh and that's a good point
there's going to be more than one
sentencing which I had forgotten about
this is not the end for Paul Manafort by
any means in any way shape or form let's
go to our caller from the
two four eight area code who's been
holding for a while who's calling from
two four eight today hey David this is
Robbie Schmo Detroit hey Robbie what's
going on uh just hanging out um recently
stumbled on your show on YouTube
excellent yeah so I had a question for
you what are your thoughts on New
Atheism and are you an atheist yourself
and why and so forth okay so let's see
my thoughts on New Atheism I so let's
see it's it's sort of hard to explain
I am very in line with a lot of the
ideas of New Atheism I sort of quantify
my religious views as I'm not religious
I don't believe in God and as soon as
there is a reason to believe in a god I
will I am just as open to the idea that
we live in a simulation that we you know
brain-in-a-vat stuff it all seems more
plausible than the idea that there's a
man in the sky who does all the stuff
etc etc so those are my personal views
that being said I think New Atheism
misses the boat on religion in one
particular way which is it doesn't
really address and what I consider to be
a serious manner the evolutionary
advantages in history to religious
belief and New Atheism from what I've
read of it and I've read a fair amount
although not not everything that's out
there New Atheism sort of characterizes
and again this is my understanding if I
mischaracterizing please let me know it
characterizes religion as almost like a
parasite or a virus and I think that
there are you know the god delusion and
the god virus or there's all these
allusions to that that have been made by
a lot of new atheists and I think that
that's misguided I think if we
understand human history we recognize
that there was an evolutionary advantage
to religion it allowed people to
coordinate and work together and
cooperate in groups that were larger
than what was previously possible based
on shared values
and you were probably better off and
sort of evolutionarily more likely to
survive if you were a believer for many
points in human history I no longer
think that that's the case in the modern
West I don't think at this point for
example I am at a disadvantage in terms
of how likely I am to be able to
cooperate with other people because I'm
not religious but I think at a certain
point that was the case and I've not
seen New Atheism really do that justice
yeah fair points all right one last
question turn at a no swinging back to
politics you've spoken on potential
candidates I want to know what you think
about potential vice presidential
candidates for the left honestly not
even thinking about it I know a lot of
people talk about Tulsi
I'm not into Tulsi so I'd rather heard
not see her on the ticket but beyond
that I'm really not thinking about VP
yet unfortunately or maybe fortunately I
don't know yeah I mean you mentioned
bado and I think he'd be really good as
a VP that's interesting yeah I mean I I
would be open to that but I'm I really
just haven't as you can probably tell
I've not given it enough thought yet
appreciate the call great to hear from
you
yeah thank you man okay let's see Sam
Dean sends a super chat g'day mate I was
wondering if you're aware of the
Cardinal George Pell case and if so what
your opinion was if any I'm proud of us
for going and getting him from the
Vatican cheers from Oz I have passing
awareness of it great that you know we
got him as they like to say but I have
not followed it as closely as maybe I
should in order to give more of an
opinion
bhisma's says what would it take for
Puerto Rico to have voting rights in our
general election think they'd want at
Trump's handling of Hurricane Maria was
awful well becoming a state would be the
most direct path
bhisma's for Puerto Rico I don't know
other than that what there would be so I
think statehood would would basically be
the way forward I do think that they
would want it they might not want
statehood but I think they would want
voting rights in the general election
okay that does it for me I've got to go
and do a whole bunch of stuff appreciate
everybody who joined me sorry I didn't
get to everybody who's holding
but I will take calls again I will
livestream again